الى اسواق المدينه هذه تتدافع عشرات الاسر
يوميا لشراء احتياجات رمضان ولعلها طقوس
اعتاد عليها سكان تعز كل عام لكن الغالبيه
منهم هذه المره قد لا يعود الى منزله بنصف
احتياجاته بسبب تدور الوضع المعيشي وانقطع
الرواتب وتراجع دخل الفرد الى معدل النصف
نتيجه الحرب الحوثيه
كنا في السابق ناخذ الحاجات الاساسيه يعني
الواحد يخرج معه 50 الف يرجع بمصاريف
رمضان كامل الان تخرج معك خمسين الف تشتري
كسبر وتروح يعني فرق شاسع بين كل في كل
سنه يستاد في هذه السنه طبعا الزياده
الزياده زياد
طبعا احنا نطالب التجار يعني برحمه
للموظفين لرحمه بالمواطنين خاصه اللي ليس
لهم دخل يعني هنا تطلق المنشدات لخفض
الاسعار بينما في المنافذ التي تسيطر
عليهم بلشه الحوثي تفرض الاتاوات والرسوم
البيهضه على البضائع والسلاح بل وتحول
وجهتها عبر طرق بعيده بسبب الحصار المفروض
على تعز منذ سنوات ما يتسبب بحسب التجار
برفع الكلفه الشرائيه للبضائع الى الضعف
ويفاقم من معاناه اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
نسمه في تعز فائل سعيد العربيه